he's the fastest player maybe we've ever
seen in the history of the sport this is
so weird
comfortable I looked through the blind
news trucks were all out in my yard
[Music]
welcome to Sims and left oh the Super
Bowl was on Monday night and it was
spectacular why because Aaron Rodgers is
the greatest quarterback we've ever seen
Kyle Shanahan is our favorite coach in
the NFL and they faced off 33 2/3 of
game and if it ends with an Aaron
Rodgers last Drive to win it it's a
beautiful game it is a beautiful game
and an Aaron Rodgers is amazing and
doing this on one leg and I just would
like to remind everybody out there you
know their offensive schematics on Green
Bay very basic a very basic the talent
on their football team there are six and
ten football team without Aaron Rodgers
you said this morning right that the
Niners are more talented position by
position than the Packers and we went
through and I kind of agree with you
it's very close nonetheless if it's not
you know if they're not better it's at
least equal but I think the G on the
helmet and number 12 at quarterback
always fools us into thinking hey
they're a Super Bowl contender and you
can see that he's got to do it all
second leading rusher on his team with
one leg I mean that's insane
Kyle Shanahan's outfit hahaha fantastic
it is I've never seen a head coach wear
a flat brim hat before no I'm pretty
sure that he was listening to Lil Wayne
during the game I mean a swagoo coming
off of Shanahan little Shanahan the Kyl
five was bumping but is this how he's
always dressed it is always how he's
dressed he grew up in San Francisco and
Denver he's got a little bit of that
skater vibe of snowboarding doing all
that so yes that's a very natural out
forum and outfit for him he's looking
cool let's not forget that Sims has Kyle
Shanahan's initials tattooed on you oh
thanks for bringing that up I appreciate
that I don't think a lot of people have
heard of that's good yeah I don't think
they've heard it either you know what
they may have not have heard what's that
it needs to change what the linebackers
for the Jets yeah Avery Williamson
Darren Lee volleyball and out yeah both
had interceptions against Andrew Luck in
the Colts this weekend they were feeling
high and mighty and they wanted to
battle Sims and I in a little game we
call best football friends
man you know my name with two R's Oh
awesome
that ain't no loss of point it's Avery
Williamson Darren Lee speedy linebackers
for the Jets and we're gonna kick their
ass what's up better than crap see
they're just taking it I know they don't
know what to say right now I'm feeling
confident very yeah I like how you guys
eager like I knew my job over in college
I'll show you this on the count of three
two three damn you have no chance I mean
none it's some stupid name yes I'm going
with his hometown and putting a prep on
the end Holland
prep sounds like a TV show damn what did
you do last year it's smoking Jam okay
yeah color Wow damn you had a bad year
for hitting Jay Cutler actually oh my
god yeah both of them waxy on Jay both
up over on dry $66,000 that's the nice
Mercedes you just lost Hank I know
you've been better off hitting him with
a Mercedes man I do know this yeah
because he has a big mouth than I heard
him telling everybody in the office they
saw it on my Instagram well like you
know I don't go there I'm ready
oh that's different
best looking at most beautiful Thanks
early on the only one that believes in
rules
wait it's so natural was having a battle
here huh hold on a second
if he doesn't get this right oh my god
we've gone through this repeat it seems
like it's around here you seemed like a
December guys you seem like a former
friend oh you got a rock oh you want to
know what's even worse tell them is I
asked him what his birthday was before
we came in here I was gone I go they
might ask me again this is so weird is
we're so comfortable yes you go okay yes
damn damn yes there is yep yep yep
open up buddy I put it down is it now
preacher in the middle yep no other way
all that all that yeah yeah yeah No
[Applause]
I'm gonna tell you balls coming cuts
cuts
[Music]
I gave them good eye my hands were in
your that's good they're clean into the
hoop left toes legs cannot move by his
arms pins I'm nervous I don't know where
this is going alright here's the first
one oh oh oh oh no he moved my feet
that's alright different moves okay move
your feet Oh nicely done
I'm the Calvin Johnson of hula-hoop
plains No
ah I found the touch watch out Oh Cho Oh
nobody comes into our house boom
four to five whoo how you like good luck
way to find your touch accent you should
probably do it
you surprised me you'll have the longest
arms are your sweat chin
nice and easy Oh God right here oh oh
there you go you got enough we got it
yes oh my god was it what money you're
supposed to be a meat head linebacker
you're not supposed to be able to do
this always getting cocky
one more point what's up are you kidding
I thought leggo
great job today's winners are Avery
Williamson and Darren Lee as you can
tell boy are they they are humble best
football friends
we're 1 & 2 man and as the coach of our
best football friends team I just
appointed myself you need to step it up
pal oh I need a step yeah you gave Avery
Williamson the key to throwing and you
forgot my birthday why did we go first
on our home turf yeah they should have
done they should have got first we run
this show I'll get your birthday right
one of these days dude say it for them
may 8th working on and when practicing
for 506 yeah hello 86 that's a special
year well Simms won a Super Bowl that
year never heard of them all right so
you know what phil was the MVP of that
Super Bowl yes and this MVPs always go
the quarterback and frankly we're tired
of it so we want to come up with our top
5 MVPs non quarterback edition I like it
and because I like you yeah I'll let you
go first number 5 oh thanks for liking
me
number 5 Tyree kill first of all Tyree
kill we have to start putting him in the
conversation would the Antonio Browns
and Odell Beckham jr. Zin Julio Jones
it's one of the best receivers in the
sport he's the most explosive receiver
in the sport he's the guy that can take
a 5 yard catch and go by everybody for
80 yard touchdowns he's the fastest
buyer maybe we've ever seen in the
history of the sport I answer than my
cane well he's up there in that
conversation with him and Deion Sanders
and Beau yes he's a special player and
he is a weapon that you really can't
always quantify what he can do to a
defense because they're always worried
about the 70 yard bomb over the top
I'm gonna go number four I'm gonna go
Melvin Gordon talk about breaking
tackles every time I turn on a Chargers
game there's people in this wake as he
steps over and jumps in he is second in
the NFL with nine total touchdowns he's
averaging over five yards of carry and
the Chargers are quietly four and two
yes and the offense is clicking and I
think Melvin Gordon is
the piece that's making them one of the
elite teams the NFL number three yes
Captain America
JJ Watt he's back he's one of the best
defensive players in football he's tied
for the league lead in sacks with seven
sacks he's tied for the league League in
forced fumbles to four forced fumbles he
is awesome he's extremely disruptive
he'd be another guy that we got to show
some love and throw them in the mix here
look at the stats the Texans defense is
shutting people down it is look at the
stats from a man Khalil Mack is Kali
Ling it oh man
so he's tied with is okay okay he's tied
with Jay Jay for four forced fumbles and
really just look at the Raiders defense
yes and then look at what he did for the
Bears defense they changed the mantra of
their team number one number one is Todd
Gurley the best running back in the NFL
right now I mean Gurley is leading the
league in yards per game as far as
rushing yards he's leading the league
with 11 touchdowns right now he's
awesome between the tackles like we saw
against the Broncos last week if there's
nothing there between the tackles he can
balance it outside and run by everybody
he's great in the pass game and he is
really the guy that makes that offense
work Todd Gurley is amazing he really is
I'm I like this list this is fun all
right so these are guys that probably
won't win the MVP because they're not
quarterbacks and there was a guy on my
favorite team the Philadelphia Eagles
who had a performance that was MVP
worthy in the Super Bowl yeah
Terrell Owens he hope but it's what
happened a year or two later that I'll
never forget what did you save to Andy
to get kicked out of camp I was home
from school and I was watching you
there's helicopters like can you take me
to that day please DISA during training
camp and this particular day it was the
receivers day to sign autographs well so
I had a growing issue at the time so I
just felt like let me use this time to
go get myself healthier in the training
room we had a bit of a disagreement and
it was like right in the doorway of
where you know people were players and
coaches so yeah and I think some other
people just you know listen to the
conversation so you know he felt like I
was showing him up and coach said go
home in the meantime he said keep
yourself in shape
why yet I'm in the house maybe 2025
minutes I start hearing helicopter
but I didn't think much of it somebody
came and knocked at the door and now I
looked through the blinds news trucks
were all out in my yard
the helicopters and everybody was around
my house I just tried to have fun with
it saw my ab bench took it outside I was
you know entertaining the the reporters
and I was working out at the same time
little did anybody know I had an
earpiece on I called my publicist at the
time she was listening to every question
that was being asked of me and so she
basically just told me kind of what to
say what not to say and so I just maybe
said no comment or whatever so did you
go back you're like Andy I was keeping
myself in shape well yeah I mean at some
point he kind of figured that out
Tio's the man Oh Cho cinco's the man
yeah and we sat with them for a long
time they talked about how hard it was
for the public to know who they really
were
yeah because the media covered them a
certain way yeah and I sit here now and
I look at odhh Elle Beckham jr. and I'm
hearing quotes from John Maris saying I
wish he'd create headlines on the field
instead of off how can he create a
headline on the field yeah when the
quarterback can't throw it more than
five yards that is exactly right what
can he do and I'll bring this to
everybody's attention I mean we haven't
heard any reports about Giants players
in the locker room not liking Odell
Beckham jr. those are the things I
listen to
there's no anonymous reports that locker
rooms / Odell Beckham jr. we've talked
to players I've talked to people with
the Giants they love Odell is loved
would you rather a guy be so passionate
on the sideline that he yells at himself
would you rather a guy on the sideline
sit like this simple question yeah and
if you're at home sitting like that Sims
do it you may have contracted a very
troubling disease called a lightest ooh
sounds serious it is yeah do you blame
the o-line for the Giants poor start do
you believe quarterbacks should be
measured by completion percentage have
you ever been arrested for defending Eli
Manning's honor if you answered yes to
any of these questions you may be
suffering from a disorder known as
alight
this condition makes otherwise rational
fans believe 37 year-old Eli Manning is
still the answer symptoms of eel itis
include yelling two rings at coworkers
and arguing that 17 is actually the
perfect amount of points to score in a
football game fortunately there is a
cure for alight us unfortunately that
cure now plays for the Jets so take your
medicine Giants fans you got what you
wanted at least say Quan is fun to watch
too bad he can't throw the ball people
watching you I play for longer than four
hours should consult a physician running
with little routes may be harmful to
your health maybe you should trade back
for Davis web that get from organ looks
pretty good maybe you could draft it
probably not as anyone reached out to
Tebow all right so thus far on somebody
and left go our Pickers have done pretty
well three and three ally IRA and Steve
but we're looking for somebody special
somebody whose pics won't be I don't
know falafel someone whose pics you
could kabob your head too
I'm looking for a gyro and that man is
the dragon so I'm tired of getting bad
information so I'm going to a guy that
only produces quality Tony dragonis aka
the dragon he breathes fire we are at
the corner of 62nd of Madison and I have
an incredible game for you on Thursday
night like Super Bowl matchup Denver
Arizona can you feel the excitement I do
yeah actually I think Devers getting
them bit the kind of those do you think
so
now here's the deal here's the line
Denver is favored by two and a half so
they have to win by two and a half do
you think they'll cover that yes because
the office of Arizona is that so strong
it is not that strong no no they haven't
been elephant's we'll see if Tony can be
my euro and get this game right see what
I did I combined
so super Steve didn't make it sorry
Scuba Steve see you next time
Slim's the Oracle is back dick and
Thursday roadies the dragon has entered
he's taking Denver minus two and a half
in Arizona he doesn't think Arizona's
offense is gonna get it done oh I'm
gonna train this dragon How to Train
Your Dragon and I'm going with him I'm
riding the dragon I'm riding it awesome
I like it I'm doubting that you learn
that from Bill Belichick now but you've
learned a lot from Bill Belichick I have
and we wish that other teams would learn
from Bella check please it's a little
thing we call wwbd
what would Belichick do and you've
noticed some trends from them this year
that you think he's exactly did this
year he drafted a between the tackles
running back in the first round he
drafted a tackle offensive tackle in the
first round I think he's going
I don't think defenses and defensive
coaches are very good at tackling
anymore they're so used to the spread
game they're not used to taking on
pulling guards and full backs and I
think we're slowly seeing New England
get back into two backs one tight end
how are old school football like we saw
on Sunday night again so you're saying
during the year where we've had more 400
yard passers up to this point than ever
before yeah Bella checks go and we're
gonna ground and pound I think that's
what we're seeing they're taking on the
Bears this weekend maybe he keeps it
running but watch the Patriots this year
if you notice things they do that other
teams don't do wwbd
be smarter follow the greatest coach of
all time right for Sims he's out homies
and the lef kod man it's always been a
pleasure enjoy the game
a lot of words you set flip okay what's
up homies thanks for watching subscribe
to the BR YouTube channel
man you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot other videos
check them out and then what time does
our show come out Wednesday 8 p.m.
be there or be square he ruined it it
was really close